c'est donc une période d'incertitude qui
s'ouvre en allemagne berlin pourrait
bien se faire discrète sur la scène
internationale avant que ne soit formé
le gouvernement paris dit espérer avoir
vite un chancelier allemand fort à ses
côtés pour faire avancer l'europe durant
sa présidence tournante de lieu ce sera
à partir du mois de janvier réaction
aussi du côté de la russie le kremlin
déclare vouloir la continuité dont les
relations avec berlin la correspondance
à moscou dont toile clairement à moscou
aussi on a suivi de près ses élections
législatives en allemagne on va
continuer de suivre les tractations à
venir dans l'optique de la formation
d'une nouvelle majorité sur afin de
connaître finalement l'identité de celui
ou celle qui va succéder à angela merkel
en tout cas du côté du kremlin une seule
chose importe conserver des relations
constructives avec berlin
les élections dans le plus grand pays
d'europe c'est un processus un événement
qui bien sûr attire l'attention du monde
entier ou presque
nous observons avec le lion d'attention
ce qui se passe quels sont les résultats
bien entendu nous comptons sur la
continuité de nos relations bilatérales
on sent par exemple de désaccord et nous
sommes unis par la compréhension qu'un
problème ne peut et ne doit être résolue
que par la voie du dialogue en outre
l'allemagne est bien entendu notre très
grand partenaire commercial économique
et d'investissement
nous avons intérêt à ce que notre
relation se prolonge et se développe
d'après ce que nous comprenons le
processus de formation d'une coalition
sera long et complexe par conséquent il
nous allons regarder comment ce
processus va se dérouler berlin est en
effet un partenaire incontournable de
moscou en europe en témoigne la
construction du gazoduc nord stream ii
entre l'allemagne et la russie via la
mer baltique qui s'est achevée il ya
tout juste quelques semaines sur ce
dossier comme sur d'autres les autorités
russes espèrent donc une continuité de
la part du nouveau gouvernement allemand
qui reste donc encore à composer